divorces i mean often religions will
actually exile a person from their
religion because they've been divorced
and if not literal exile it will be
communal exile to be everyone will talk
about them and and so all these things
shape when we're attached to a
relationship
which
you know you think about romantic
relationships are obviously different
than uh friendships in that we're
potentially creating a family with them
we're potentially sharing a life with
them
that's a lot of shared time that's a lot
of shared meals that's a lot of shared
moments and
that i mean puts a lot more weight or we
might be more attached because it is
more destabilizing to know your partner
and your relationship might end
um and i think part of the biological
process of processing heartbreak
is the recognition that a story we
thought was going to happen is no longer
happening and
you know when they look at the research
at people's brains they light up in the
same place when they think about their
ex as a cocaine addict so you know we we
kind of become addicted to them and so
part of the physiological process of
losing a romantic partner is the story
the possibility you know we don't
realize that
although the story in how we envisioned
it is changing and the person we're with
is maybe not that person anymore we can
still create that life and we think it's
the death of the whole future rather
than just the
how it looks and and part of the
attachment to how it needs to look is
what makes us hold on and stay static in
relationship and
you know one of the things i've argued
for a long time is is because we're so
afraid of relationships ending we
actually oscillate and participate in
the relationship in a way that reduces
the amount of friction in the
relationship because we're afraid this
conversation might end the relationship
not seeing that that's the same
conversation that also would deepen it
we're invited to deep it the idea that
all relationships all
are selfish in nature and self-serving i
mean true because you think we're always
getting something from it and you know
even the self-abandonment is is selfish
because you just want to be with them so
it's really self-serving it's not you
know what i mean like that everything is
to serve the self and what you think
will make you happier or feel better and
that's why survival-based behaviors or
mechanisms that we learn from childhood
to self-abandon to people-please to even
overtly individuate and become an island
that never gets connection they're all
ways to protect us from being hurt and
also to ensure connection i mean
most of us till we do
most of us don't know how do i hold on
to a self and be in relationship to
another person
we often either put at cost our
relationship to ourselves for the
connection to other or the connection to
other
uh at the cost to self so it's either
one or the other we don't tend
you know we don't know how to do both
how do i hold on to me and be in love
with you and allow you and me too you
know those are that's hard i would
imagine those are secure secure
attachment as those rare unicorns that
can find the balance and there's
wherever those
um the anxious attachment which would be
abandoning the self for the abandoning
yourself for the other person for the
connection and then the
and the avoidant would be
are those the sort of categories that
you're applying when you say that the
avoidant would abandon the relationship
for the self
yeah exactly you know and are your
listeners familiar with attachment
theory and yeah i mean somewhat i'm i'm
sure we get some new people here and
there but i've definitely broached it
many times with different people but if
you want to give a quick overview i
think that's what was great
yeah i mean essentially what you're
saying a secure attachment is the sort
of defining characteristic is my
partner's needs or the other person's
needs matter as much as my own and so
not more than my own which would be more
anxious attachment not less than my own
which would be more avoidant and you
know the
the beautiful thing is no matter what we
might think our attachment style is it
can change so when someone learns it
they often say i'm anxiously attached no
you're just prone to anxious attachment
but if you say i am then you're gonna
stay in it right you can't identify with
the thing so all of us can learn secure
attachment the reason it's based on
research by jonathan baubie originally
and they had a mom with a baby and the
mom would leave the room and come back
and then they'd observe how did baby
interact with mom
when the mom came back and the baby was
like anxious attaches to mom it's like
ah you know when you leave i'm not sure
you're coming back it's essentially the
behavior so as soon as mom comes back in
the room they don't leave mom's side so
there's not really a trust there the
second one mom leaves mom comes back
baby's like hey what's up reconnects
with mom goes back to playing that's
more secure and the last one more
avoidant mom leaves mom comes back
baby's like didn't even really know you
were gone not a big deal acts as if it's
not affecting them but internally
physiologically they're experiencing the
same thing as the anxious child so you
could think about it like
anxious people
get triggered by space in relationship
yeah avoiding people get triggered by a
lack of space so both are experiencing
insecure attachment they're just
be they're just protecting themselves
from hurt in opposite ways exactly right
so
you're right though you're dead on like
the avoidant
is will distance from the relationship
to protect self so the cost is the
relationship not the self as opposed to
an anxious person is like
becomes a doormat which kind of points
in the direction of
like
child work in her child work i think
there's a lot of people that don't do
any of this but is it essential if you
are growing in a relationship to do
inner child work to understand your
patterns to understand
um your attachment style and all that
stuff because it just seems like when
you know
it's really part of your life and i can
remember old you know old times in my
life where i had no idea what any of
this was and i just sort of took
everything personally and it was
everybody else's fault but it's not a
lot of joy either so
oh man that was so mean too like when i
think about
being in high school or university
how i was normally more of anxious
secure and then i got really hurt and
betrayed and then i became very avoidant
and
you know that's why it's so easy to
oscillate between the two anxious and
avoidant because you're you don't have
to learn security right you can they're
both insecure attachment style so you
don't have to become secure
and you know that was when i was 19 so
my attachment style dramatically changed
at 19. and that was because after being
experiencing betrayal
i made it mean that when i love people
they betray me and you know here i am
you know not making out on dance floors
while my buddies are some of them are
doing that and talking about it and i'm
like you know no one's in a locker room
being like man monogamy is the best like
my partner and i we had a deeper
conversation and we found another level
of intimacy you know like that's not
often the conversation that's going on
in a locker room
um
so you know really very for
many more decades after that
right and relational awareness only
can't you know i originally used to
actually be in sales but also teach
sales techniques and all that kind of
stuff and
you know when i went through a breakup i
thought to myself why am i so good at
talking about all these things but not
my feelings like that's not a skill set
issue there's something else going on
here and so that was the beginning of my
journey of wanting to understand
romantic relationships which inevitably
if you begin to understand romantic
relationships
your every relationship will improve you
know because it's just a magnifying
glass of the things you don't do well
and
i i believe there might be people who
don't believe what we believe because i
totally agree with you i think
any
i think people can create really
fulfilling relationships without any
awareness of why they do what they do
they just happen to be modeled really
healthy relational dynamics that doesn't
tend to be the norm and i would even say
what were modeled by disney or romantic
comedies or romantic movies it tends to
be codependency tends to be like
self-abandonment you know like the
woman's laying on the tracks are up in
the tower waiting to be saved so one is
needing to be saved and the other one
always needs to be a night you know it's
there's just so much of that [ __ ]
that goes on in the unconscious and even
our
roles that we took on in our families as
kids we often try to take on in a
romantic relationship so
you know i think both people to
have deeply fulfilling relationships
need to have awareness of what their
limitations are and where their skill
sets aren't um because we don't learn
this [ __ ] in school like no you didn't
you know like i started a podcast about
it too and i started writing them back
because i was like i gotta learn this
stuff like this is more important than
whether i have a sales award i'd rather
have a stable romantic relationship you
know the interesting thing is you'll
likely get the sales award so you know
that's the irony it starts at home and
there's so much happiness driven from
like your emotional
position of where you're at i think the
real question with that is is how right
i think even if someone says
oh yeah i i i want to learn about myself
right i want to do a good job or i want
to know i mean
how you know i i mean i've been you've
been doing this longer than i have for
sure but even just my experience you
have to really be driven to excavate you
have to be driven to dig into
your um psyche and your patterns and
analyze your family which i'm sure has
been hurtful at times you know like i
don't know i've hurt my family in the
process my parents especially you know
and um
um i mean and i always have love and
reverence for them but
your your patterns come from them so
like what does someone do if they are
hearing it and they feel like oh you
know i have these you know i'm not in a
relationship or i'm not happy and you
know what what does someone do to become
aware awareness hard
right i think that ability to have
awareness of your awareness right to be
aware of your patterns to be willing to
ask questions i mean i think the birth
of awareness is asking the question or
the feeling i think there's more to this
you know i feel like i'm tired of this
pattern i'm tired of this feeling
you know it usually that's kind of the
crazy thing about being human maybe it's
true about
being a dog too i don't know but
what's crazy about being human is we
tend to wait till we have to change or
we're in some space where it hurts so
much that we have to listen and
or do research and you know you're i
think you're dead on you know you start
to learn about your family and then all
of a sudden you're like my childhood was
effed you know or like this was that and
you you might have anger towards your
parents and i think one thing that
allows us in the exploration and the
excavation of these things is to see our
parents as the children of parents
because then we start to see that you
know they were handed down the same
thing and
you know where do you begin
for me it's always been following the
breadcrumbs i feel like when you ask the
question much like that saying is uh
when the when the student's ready the
teacher arrives and
i think that's true you know i have had
so many incredible teachers that have no
idea they were my teachers
a lot of them just from reading their
books or consuming their information
where i got to learn about something i
was curious about and you know that
that's you know your podcast is an
incredible example of that and
um you know we there's so many resources
available to us it might be someone
today gets this inkling of
oh inner child what the hell's an inner
child you know
and then they could literally just
google that and find out what that means
i think that's a beautiful thing about
where we're at today i think you're
right
[Music]